então
algumas semanas atrás eu recebi um
presente incrível fantástico
esse prêmio não é um troféu
não é uma condecoração é uma capa de
revista
esse prêmio é isso aqui uma conversa
rápida do facebook com um amigo meu
chama bruno tellechea ele falou
basicamente vicar esses dias eu estava
pensando em pessoas que eu considero
realizadas profissionalmente e foi a
primeira pessoa que eu pensei ficar com
incrível demais isso obrigado bruno
então tal cara e ea partir desse prêmio
que recebi
comecei a refletir muito respeito de
estar realizado choca um pouco enxergar
algo tão relevante algo tão um incrível
tão necessário à nossa vida a gente
debate está um pouco a gente pensa tão
pouco sobre isso a gente troca receita
de bolo mas não troca receitas de como
ter uma vida realizada a gente pensa
quais são os problemas da seleção
brasileira pra que precisam ser
resolvidos para o brasil ganhar a copa
do mundo a gente não pensa quais são os
problemas
a gente precisa resolver para que a
nossa vida se torna completa realizada e
quando normalmente quando a gente vê um
debate falando a respeito disso pessoas
comentando sobre ser realizado ter uma
vida completa é o nível é muito
superficial assim o cara que está
realizado faz o que gosta
não basta fazer o que gosta sim eu podia
ficar o dia inteiro jogando futebol
ainda no cinema realizada não é também
1º que encheu o saco sabe
segundo que não é comum isso tentar
fazer as coisas que eu gostaria de fazer
e esse já é um gancho para o segundo
nível de segunda camada da discussão que
está então trabalha com que gosta
não basta trabalhar com o que gosta nós
poderia estar no meio do futebol do
catar no meio da festa de cinema e sim
não basta pra ter uma vida realizada e
aí nesse momento a gente bate de frente
com uma uma reflexão mais profunda e é
muito comum a gente dá um passo atrás
assim pegar nossas trouxinhas e voltar
para o mundo real fosse em casa
sim é a fantasia de desenho da disney ou
história de hollywood beleza vou fazer
meu trabalho direitinho
vou curtir o tempo livre com a família
com os amigos e bola pra frente vamos
nessa
quando eu era bem moleque tiver uns 10
ou 11 anos de idade
eu estava vendo televisão na sala de
casa com a minha família e tinha aqueles
casos mega polêmicos assim que era o tal
do caso suzane von richthofen acusada de
mandar um namorado matar a família
enquanto dormia uma parada punk assim e
aí na televisão estava o advogado de
suzane fez não porque é uma injustiça a
opinião pública está colocando ela como
vilã e não é verdade tal eu perguntei
para minha mãe fosse mãe
acho que esse cara acredita no que ele
está dizendo que minha mãe não falam ser
polido não sei como a gente todo mundo
tem direito à defesa comum dar o direito
dela poder trazer a versão dela vamos
entender um pouco do centro muito
acredita nesse cara mesmo que ele está
falando ah não sei
é bom digamos que ele também não saiba
se na frente do juiz
enquanto tiver o acusador e o acusado
expondo os seus argumentos eo advogado
de pontos encara na minha cliente está
errada se ele vai levantar a mão e
desembarque só juízes mesmo toca ficha
toca na jaula e assim caras
me perguntava muito se o cara tá
defendendo que o cara tá defendendo a
justiça o que ele acredita hoje está
defendendo a cliente dele ou sendo um
pouco mais preciso o dinheiro que a
cliente ele está pagando pra ele e aí a
resposta era sempre a ele é tão ingênua
daniel leão vai para o mundo real
o advogado o trabalho dele é isso aí
mesmo cardíaco cada real não tem nada de
errado é só uma forma de ver o mundo e
me batia muito com o que eu acreditava
que era genuíno sendo contaminado aos
poucos por uma cultura externa existente
que vai se acostumando e vai fazendo com
que o advogado faz parte e quando se dá
conta que está sendo tão influenciado
que começa a achar comum opiniões que
são exatamente opostas ao que acredita
genuinamente isso acontece desde as
coisas mais simples assim o moleque ea
galera foi um relógio tem que botar a
mão esquerda assim porque a direita não
tem que botar a mão esquerda porque
diabos ou enfim o botão do eterno não
não sabotou o último botão de perto
assim porque até coisas um pouco mais
complexas como como é que a gente tem
coragem de passar na rua e não olhar no
olho de uma pessoa que está atirada no
chão suja mas quando fomos que estende o
braço diz por favor me ajuda a passar
por essa pessoa em que momento em que
perdeu a conexão de passar por essa
pessoa tipo tá beleza num bom nem me dar
o luxo de olhar para si ou como um dono
de uma empresa têm coragem de ter um
salário 20 30 50 vezes maior do que um
funcionário que o empréstimo não
consegue dar um
tudo razoável os seus filhos como ele
tem coragem de ter um salário 50 cem
vezes maior e tem novo externo começou a
me contaminar isso assim não isso é
normal faz parte o lado lúdico tem que
fazer da vida não o salário é maior
porque o valor que ele gera tal é maior
ea gente vai se acostumando por mais que
a gente não acredite nisso então colégio
informei a faculdade de publicidade e
propaganda me formei e comecei a
trabalhar em agências de publicidade e
eu sempre fui um cara que gostei muito
de trabalhar pauleira ficar até altas
horas
certo dia estava duas e meia da manhã
três da manhã trabalhando na agência
para um produto que eu não gostava
acreditava que eles punham uma causa que
não fazia sentido pra mim e me parecia o
discurso não era verdadeiro e eu estava
criando argumentos para que pessoas que
não precisavam comprar aquele produto
que às vezes não tinha nem dinheiro para
comprar aquele produto comprassem o
produto e eu trabalhando há um link ou a
conexão entre o produto e aquelas
pessoas tudo um virtude de foi aí que me
dei conta que estava sendo o advogado
que é o tanto criticava quando era
moleque e eu enfim uma pirada comecei um
trabalho de desconstrução muito forte
esquecer essa cultura externa que aos
poucos foi tentando jogar algumas
verdades realidade de que existentes
construir o nosso discurso quando a
gente tem que construir o nosso discurso
e reconectado nos propósitos com que eu
acreditava genuinamente nesse processo
de autoconhecimento além de pedir
demissão eu quebrei algumas empresas
teve projetos bem sucedidos alguns
fracassos são idosos e eu cheguei nessa
história chamada smile flamengo que me é
uma iniciativa que cria
netos com impacto positivo na sociedade
através da felicidade
então são projetos que em outras
palavras a gente fala que são malucos e
do bem assim
e pra entender um pouco melhor e
resolveu simplificar e a gente tem
alguns cases muito legais primeiro
beleza é o skate no asilo
a gente criou um campeonato de skate
dentro de um asilo porque ao invés de
ficar levando sopinha na boquinha da
vovó ou ficar lendo jornal com um voo
dos casos um negócio rock'n'roll que os
vovôs e vovós possam curtir ea galera
que pensa parecido com a gente possa
curtir junto então eles eram os jurados
do evento significa que os caras os
caras muito bons que tinham realmente 16
que os fortes dentro do skate perderam
para os caras com isso porque os vovôs e
vovós curtir um cara seria legal gostei
aqui tem outras plaquinhas assim caiu do
telhado bolso eles davam as notas era
bem divertido bem legal porque as
polêmicas é outro projeto que ele fez
que é incrível é a corrida maluca de
cadeirantes que os educadores em geral
eles vão fazer um trabalho físico com as
crianças noite é bom jogar futebol fazer
um pega pega
vamos fazer uma apostar uma corrida e as
crianças cadeirantes normalmente acabam
ficando excluídos dessa história e mais
do que incluir a molecada cadeirante
dentro dessa história a gente quis fazer
um projeto que elas fossem a estrela que
elas participassem de todo o processo
desde a concepção de um carrinho até a
execução e o evento principal que é a
corrida em si
então a gente pega as cadeiras de rodas
e faz mega customizações a partir da
lógica da cadeira de rodas do carrinho
de hambúrgueres tinha um navio pirata
penélope charmosa esse ano vai ter uma
baterista que a gente tá fazendo vai vai
acontecer muito legal ea bota do mundo a
ter seu projeto que eu vim exemplificar
o que a gente tem feito que é uma copa
do mundo para crianças deficientes que
nunca chutaram uma bola de futebol na
vida fazerem o primeiro gol da sua
história então través de uma botinha
especial que ela aprende os pés da
criança com um adulto é a gente faz um
campeonato de pênaltis que essa molecada
possa se divertir jogando bola então
participar base da luz como dunga ou
barcos do tinga esse ano neymar
participou foi muito legal foi incrível
para felicidade da criança sentido caras
essa é a sensação de fazer um gol que
coisa incrível
a unei março participou da história em
ficar como diabos eu conseguir ter uma
idéia há dois três anos atrás nem marta
participando hoje em dia é algo muito
surreal
enfim a partir preciso dessa lógica
eu comecei a ver que eu estava cada vez
mais me aproximando a o que eu
acreditava genuinamente então assim
olhado por um morador de rua e que
ninguém passava e olhava no olho e dizer
cara agora tem uma empresa que trata
todo ser humano de forma humana
todo mundo quando eu estava na agência
estava vendendo um tênis que eu não
acreditava cara agora tem empresa que
todo mundo acredita no que vende se não
acredito que vende cada ano não pode
estar dentro da empresa
o salário que é 50 100 vezes maiores que
eu ficava louco de enxergar se ouse
donos da empresa hoje em dia o salário é
discutido em todo mundo dentro da
empresa inclusive já tiveram salários
que mudaram de valor a partir da
discussão do todo da empresa porque a
gente acredita nisso sabe isso faz
sentido e inclusive bônus de venda
repartido de forma igual para todas as
pessoas então é muito legal sem muito
bacana ver que o que eu acreditava tá
começando a ser exemplificado dentro da
empresa
porque não basta fazer o que gosta
não basta trabalhar com o que gosta
a gente tem que ser o que a gente
acredita e todos nós todos nós somos
únicos
então quem tiver a sensibilidade ea
capacidade de poder entender nosso
propósito nossa essência
os nossos resultados também vão ser
únicos
então vamos levantar a bunda dessas
cadeiras para construir o mundo que a
gente sonha viver porque só assim a
gente vai conseguir caminhar em direção
a uma vida completa uma vida de
realizações como todos muito obrigado